for the tampa bay rays here tonight it's
going to be left-hander shane mcclanahan
making his 21st start of the season and
looking to keep it rolling his month of
august fantastic
starts a 5-0 record and a 2.76 earned
run average in the month trying to roll
that here in september as the rays head
down the stretch run here's renfro
leading off for the second time in this
series second time in his career
honoring smacks it hard on the ground in
a right field and that's how he greets
shane mcclanahan with a leadoff single
two men down for rafi
finds this one the opposite way for a
base hit
so a two out single for devers and some
more hard contact here off mcclanahan
red sox have runners at first and second
here's bobby dalbeck the american league
rookie of the month and he lines this
one the opposite way to right field
renfro rounds third
and the red sox strike first boy the red
sox are on attack mode that's exactly
what they need they got to get loud here
in the first inning they get rewarded
finally it's eduardo rodriguez coming
off seven innings friday in cleveland
don't say that very often a little seven
inning piece nowadays tied a season high
for him it was the most pitches he had
thrown all year 109 and he gets a first
pitch roller to second that is jack
lopez in his second big league game
throwing out randy arose arena tom
nelson crows at 270 overall with 26
homers and he goes to the changeup
that's a beauty to strike out cruz you
got to get ready gear yourself 95 and
then all of a sudden three finger piece
that doesn't get there
nicely done brings up wander franco for
his young shortstop bounces this one
back to rodriguez
throws out franco in a one two three
first on 11 pitches first game back for
danny santana off the groin injury
hasn't played since july 21st lead off
walk danny santana coaxes that off
mcclanahan so alex cora's gotta like
what he sees so far and it brings up
jack lopez out of the eighth spot again
starting at second in his second career
big league game and he pushes a bunt
toward first tries to elude the tag but
yandy diaz slapped it on lopez for out
number one here's hunter renfro one
nothing boston with a speedy runner
santana at second and two out there you
go renfro pulls it into left field to
base it it'll get santana in from second
and the red sox lead two nothing here in
saint pete line drive to right and now
it's time to pull the ball breaking ball
i told you a center cut i mean that's
like hit me all over it after a biting
breaking ball he throws a hanger he's
lucky it stays in the ball park just a
base hit but a run scores
waving him in
alex cora likes what he sees from hunter
renfro out of the lead off spot again
257 for margot with nine homers
that's a fly ball hit well the left
martinez back and in front of the wall
he makes the catch
just not quite enough right there
on that 2-1 pitch
one two on the way and it's cut on and
miss
two perfect innings out of the gates
from eduardo rodriguez and martinez is
aboard here's rafael
up the middle behind the bag franco will
step on it throw to first into the
runner and diaz gets the tag to complete
the double play and boy that certainly
helps
the double play
franco to diaz fell back drove in a run
with a base sent to right in the first
did he go
yes he did
dehydrates down there at first and
dawnback
offered him so that's out number three
no runs ahead double play in that inning
and we're headed into the bottom of the
third the 2-2 swinging a line drive on
the right side into the outfield for a
base hit and zanino is aboard to lead
off the third
roller to short could be two the flip
lopez's turn
dulbeck digs it and it is a double play
behind rodriguez two down bases clear
here's taylor walls 3-2
got him swinging that'll put a smile on
eddie's face he blows walls away
his way to the plate left side scooped
by franco throw to first
right there
bronco coming in from shortstop
that ball slowly hit looks like taylor
walls making his way toward it as franco
was coming in and look how he pulls off
right there concedes to franco nice
scoop and throw fifth inning red sox
leading two nothing over the rookie
phenom shane mcclanahan red sox will
this will send up
11th pitch from mcclanahan to our ooze
and it's outside ball four wow
flanagan's got to be annoyed by that he
threw 11 pitches in the entirety of the
fourth inning
and 11 there to the nine hole hit so
brings up kyle schwarber over two couple
of k's
he goes the opposite way in the left
field for a base hit first and second
for the red sox here in the fifth inning
this is a big opportunity here this came
in and jd pulls it around races around
third and jd martinez adds to the red
sox lead it is three nothing in the
fifth yeah that ball wasn't down away
that ball is down and in a little
breaking ball and he makes him pay all
right so two still out there two out now
for bobby dulbeck first pitch swinging
right center field and it drops down
schwarber comes around and scores and
dullback delivers yeah the beat goes on
for bobby dawback he's got it going on
ball down and in
fights it off just flips it out to right
center field pretty good stuff so far
for erod tonight five innings two hits
hasn't walked anyone see what he goes to
for a put away on a 2-2
oh yeah got him 94 and a strikeout for
e-rod and he has faced the minimum
through four and a third eleven steals
for manuel margot this year now brandon
lau at the plate one two again yes
there's the breaking ball and lau
strikes out conley's still in there came
on in the sixth couple of breaking balls
nothing in two on schwarber he has seen
a lot of breaking balls tonight he
didn't think that was a strike this guy
knows the strike zone
pulls this one into right field to base
it
two strikes on him doesn't matter i want
to bring up deborah's
one for three the o2 again
and he chases downstairs back-to-back
caves for conley but there's a change up
down do you get a piece of this thing no
he's still there endeavors is hot i know
did we miss something carlos fables is
trying to calm down rafael devers
the rays trying to get something going
here
shut out on three hits tonight under
franco set the lead off the bottom of
the seventh inning ground ball foul
outside of third mark vincent's coming
out and
it's like he's either you know again got
something in his ear or had a headache
or something i don't know
he says he's okay he's a 3-2 and he
draws the walk so franco will continue
that on-base streak he extends it to
consecutive games and joey wendell will
run for him the 2-2 pitch on its way
swinging a looper into center field
that's going to get down for a base in
on the play to santana wendell the
second he's going to stop there in the
raise
get a man to second base for the first
time tonight and have two on base for
the first time tonight out goes
rodriguez a terrific job for the
left-hander today and yet his fate is
still yet to be determined it's 4-0
boston richards coming on two on nobody
out for the race in the seventh and well
mark go at the plate richard's one-two
pitch he got him swinging
went right back to it and there's one
down now brandon lau with one out and
two aboard still for the raise that is
strike three called
top of the zone for richards two down
two away now and it's mike sunino
zunino in the air left center but there
is room for santana and he makes the
catch
all right garrett richards gets the job
done rodriguez in line for the win it
scared richards back out for a third
inning boys a big boy saved so wendell
is on now the cleanup man yandy diaz and
he swings through it it's strike three
one away here's mark goes one two
on the ground devers comes up with it
and gets the force at second and there's
two down
what a play by devers that ball was
stung and he got to this in a heartbeat
and now brandon lowe 2-1
swinging a high pop-up
shallow left jd coming on he's there and
he has it and the red sox split the
series
they shut out the tampa bay raising the
red section out within a game and a half
of the yankees for second place in the
first wild card and remain two in front
of
oakland for the second wild card